Шановні колеги дійсно режим правового
стан правовий режим воєнного стану
показав низку проблем з яких треба
терміново які потрібно вирішувати і це
точно не про передачу корпоративних прав
а на майно до підпорядкування
міністерству оборони України нам
сьогодні треба вирішувати питання про
додаткові
тренування наших бійців територіальної
оборони які сьогодні у лавах збройних
сил у гордо захищають і гідно захищають
нашу країну і Тому ми наполягаємо на
тому що ви законопроект 9006 від
європейської солідарності який
передбачає створення центрів
інструкторських тренінгових центрів був
поставлений на голосування
режим правовий режим воєнного стану На
жаль говорить про те що Верховна Рада
України Взагалі вирішила ховатися від
людей Але одночасно і це Ми щойно бачили
на вашому голо запитання і одночасно ми
бачимо нову пропозицію про виділення
додаткових 200 мільйонів гривень на Що
на російськомовний телеканал Freedom
колеги нам треба вирішувати питання
фінансування збройних сил України а не
ховати голову в пісок і ганебно не
хотіти показати
нашим громадянам А що ж відбувається в
Верховній Раді і як вона працює Ну і
третє знаєте
На жаль ми маємо певну проблему з
демократичним контролем над військовою
над військовим сектором України сьогодні
але ми маємо одночасно і втручання
політичного керівництва країни у
призначення військовослужбовців і мені
соромно Я сподіваюся що вам так само
соромно за те що понижують у звані
понижують понижують у можливостях гідних
наших захисників за те що вони відверто
в Західній пресі говорять про потреби
наших збройних сил нам пора звернути
увагу на потреби